all right dave please just make a smile
the world needs some
you know we need some some joys to smile
yeah we need a smile
kanye west has a real friend in dave
chappelle
real friends how many of us how many of
us
how many jealous real friends after the
rapper made some
controversial comments during his
presidential campaign rally in south
carolina over the weekend
and on twitter monday the comedian flew
out to see him in wyoming where he's
staying
kanye thanked him for being a quote true
friend
all right dave please just make us smile
the world needs some
you know we need some some joy
yay tweeted that clip tuesday writing
dave
you are a godsend and a true friend
all love uplifting joke now you know i
don't write though
now a source tells e.t the 46 year old
funny man flew out to wyoming to be
there for his longtime friend
dave knows how much hollywood and the
people around you can make
or break you and took time off years ago
to get away from it all
the source added that dave flew out the
second he could
to be there with kanye and support him
dave just wanted to be there for kanye
and help him with anything he needed
thanks for coming
of course dave's visit comes after kanye
delivered an emotional speech at his
presidential campaign rally in south
carolina over the weekend
where he said he considered an abortion
when his wife kim kardashian was
pregnant with their first child
north even if my wife were to divorce me
after this speech she brought north
into the world even when i didn't want
to
she stood up and she protected that
child a day later the 43
year old took aim at kim and her mom
kris jenner in a string of since-deleted
tweets
claiming that they tried to lock me up
and on tuesday night in another
now-deleted tweet kanye claimed he's
been considering a divorce for years
but a source tells et that kim is
standing by her man's side
and is not planning to divorce kanye
he's just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things
that might get misinterpreted
and people don't see the context behind
it on wednesday kim broke her silence
posting a lengthy message on instagram
about her husband
and his battle with bipolar disorder
asking for compassion
and empathy from the public i've seen
him go through
a lot but i always know his heart